let's say we have the following
second-order differential equation we
have the second derivative of y plus
four times the first derivative plus 4y
is equal to zero and we're asked to find
the general solution to this
differential equation so the first thing
we do like we've done in the last
several videos we'll get the
characteristic equation that's R squared
plus 4 R plus 4 is equal to 0 this one's
fairly easy to factor we don't need the
quadratic equation here this is R plus 2
times R plus 2 and now something
interesting happens something that we
haven't seen before the two roots of our
characteristic equation are actually the
same number R is equal to minus 2 so you
can say we only have one solution or one
root or a repeated root however you want
to say it we only have one R that
satisfies the characteristic equation so
you might say well that's fine
maybe my general solution is just Y is
equal to some constant times e to the
minus 2x using my one solution and my
reply to you is this is a solution then
and if you don't believe me you can test
it out but it's not the general solution
and why do I say that because this is a
second-order differential equation and
if someone wanted a particular solution
they would have to give you two initial
conditions the two initial conditions
we've been using so far are what Y of 0
equals and what Y prime of 0 equals you
could have you know but you could they
could give you what Y of 5 equals who
knows but in general when you're having
a set when you have a second order
differential equation they have to give
you two initial conditions now the
problem with this solution and why it's
not the general solution is if you use
one of these initial conditions you can
solve for C right you could you'll get
an answer you'll solve for that C but
then there's nothing to do with the
second initial condition and in fact
except for only in one particular case
whatever C you get for the first initial
condition it won't be
that this equation won't be true for the
second initial condition and you could
try it out I mean if we said Y of zero
is equal to a and y prime of 0 is equal
to I don't know five a let's see if
these work if Y is 0 is equal to a
what's so that tells us that a is equal
to C times e to the minus 2 times 0 so e
to the 0 or C is equal to a right so if
you just had this first initial
condition say fine my particular
solution is y is equal to a times e to
the minus 2x but let's see if this
particular solution satisfies the second
initial condition so what's the
derivative of this Y prime is equal to
minus 2a e to the minus 2x and it says
that 5 5 a this initial condition says
that 5 a is equal to minus 2 a times e
to the minus 2 times 0 so e to the 0 or
another way of saying that E is 0 is
just 1 it says that 5 a is equal to
minus 2 a which we know is not true so
no note when we only have this general
silora pseudo general solution it can
only satisfy generally one of the
initial conditions and if we're really
lucky both initial conditions so that at
least gives you an intuitive feel of why
this isn't the general solution so let
me clean that up a little bit so that I
could have a feeling off to use this
real estate so what do we do so we can
use a technique called reduction of
order and it really just says well let's
just guess a second solution you know in
general when we first thought about
these linear constant-coefficient
differential equations we said well e to
you know our X might be a good guess and
why is that because all of the
derivatives of e are kind of you know
multiples of the original function and
that's why we used it so if we're
looking for a second solution it doesn't
hurt to kind of make the same guess in
order to be a little bit more general
let's make our guest for our second
solution I'll call this G for guess
say it's some function of x times our
first solution e to the minus 2x I could
say some function of x times C times e
to the minus 2x but the C is kind of
encapsulated it could be part of this
some random function of X so let's be as
general as possible so let's assume that
there is this is a solution and and then
substitute it back into our original
differential equation and see if we can
actually solve for V that makes it all
work so before we do that let's get its
first and second derivatives so the
first derivative of G is equal to well
this is product rule and I'll drop the V
of X we know that V is a function and
not a constant so product rule
derivative of the first V prime times
the second expression e to the minus 2x
plus the first function or expression
times the derivative of the second so
minus 2 times e to the minus 2x so x
minus 2 e to the minus 2x or just to
write a little bit neater G prime is
equal to V prime e to the minus 2x minus
2v e to the minus 2x now we have to get
the second derivative I'll do that in a
different color just to fight the
monotony of it so the second derivative
we're going to do the product rule twice
derivative of this first expression it's
going to be V prime prime e to the minus
2x minus 2 V prime e to the minus 2x
that was just the product rule again and
then the derivative of the second
expression is going to be and see the
derivative the first one is V prime so
it's going to be minus 2 V prime e to
the minus 2x times or pono plus I'm just
probably rule 2 minus 2 times minus 2
plus 4v e to the minus 2x I hope I
haven't made a careless mistake and we
can simplify this a little bit so we get
the second
Rivet of G which is our guests solution
is equal to the second derivative of V
prime e to the minus 2x minus 2 V Prime
no minus 4
sorry I could we have minus 2 minus 2
minus 4 V prime e to the minus 2x plus
4v e to the minus 2x and now before we
substitute it into this we can just make
one observation that'll just make the
algebra a little bit simpler notice that
G is something times e to the minus 2x G
prime is we could factor out an e to the
minus 2x and G prime prime we can factor
out an e to the minus 2x so let's factor
them out essentially so we can when we
write this we can write so the second
derivative is G prime prime which we can
write as and I'm gonna try to do this
it's e to the minus 2x times the second
derivative so now we can get rid of the
e to the minus 2x terms so that's V
prime prime minus 4v prime plus 4v right
if I just distribute this out I get the
second derivative which is this plus 4
times the first derivative and I'm also
going to factor out the e to the minus
2x so plus 4 times this so it's going to
be plus 4v prime minus 8v right minus 8
V once again I factored out the e to the
minus 2x right plus 4 times y so plus 4
times we factored out the e to the minus
2x so plus 4 times V I did that because
if I didn't do that I'd be writing e to
the minus 2x and I'd probably make a
careless mistake and I'd run out of
space etc but anyway I essentially to
get this I just substituted the second
derivative the first derivative and G
back into the differential equation and
we know that that has to equal 0 let's
see if we can simplify this
a little bit more and then hopefully
hopefully solve for V so let's see some
things are popping out at me so I have
plus 4 V plus 4 v plus 4 V that's plus 8
V minus HV right so plus 4 minus 8 plus
4 those cancel out it's plus 8 minus 8
those cancel out and then I also have
minus 4 V prime plus 4 V prime so those
cancel out and lo and behold we've done
some serious simplification it ends up
being e to the minus 2x times V prime
prime we could call it V prime prime of
X now that we've saved so much space is
equal to 0 we know this could never
equal to 0 so essentially we have now
established that this that this
expression has to be equal to 0 and we
get a separable second-order
differential equation we get that the
second derivative of V with respect to X
or it's a function of X is equal to 0 so
now we just have to differentiate both
sides of this equation twice you
differentiate once you get what V V
prime V prime of X is equal to let's
call it c1 and if we were to take the
antiderivative both sides again we get V
of X is equal to c1 x c1 X plus some
other c2 right now remember what was our
guess our guess was thought that our
solution was going to be or our general
solution was going to be some arbitrary
function V times kind of that first
solution solution we found e to the
minus 2x and when we actually took that
guess and we substitute it in we
actually were able to solve for that V
and we got the V is equal to this so
this is interesting so what is G or what
is our guest function equal it's no
longer and guess we've kind of
established that it works G which we can
call our solution is equal to V V of x
times e to the minus 2x well that equals
this
C 1 X plus C 2 e to the minus 2x that
equals C 1 X e to the minus 2x plus C 2
e to the minus 2x this is an e and now
we have a truly general solution we have
two constants so we can satisfy two
initial conditions and if you are
looking for pattern this is the pattern
when you have a repeated root of your
characteristic equation the general
solution is going to be is going you're
going to use that e to the that whatever
root is twice but one time you're going
to have an X in front of it and this
works every time for second order
homogeneous constant coefficient linear
equations I will see you in the next
video